To compute the average, you first need to compute the sum using the algorithm
from lesson seven, we traverse all elements in the array. Ask each of it for
its area and sum them all up. Then we return the sum over the count, which is
the sum over the length of the array. And as you can see here, I was a little
nervous. What if someone gives me an array of length zero, then I don't want to
divide by zero. So, I'm checking for that, and in the admittedly unlikely case
that I do get an empty array, I return zero. When you run the program, It gives
you an average area of about 75,000 square kilometers. That's actually not very
large, it's a bit larger than West Virginia. Next, let's see how we can compute
the average of another set of objects.